BRIAN CAIRNS: Hello, everyone.
I'm Brian Cairns.
CHERYL SIMON: I'm
Cheryl Simon.
BRIAN CAIRNS: And we're going to
tell you a little bit about
the secrets behind the
Drive Realtime API.
So what does that mean?
Well first, we're going to give
you a brief introduction
to the Realtime API and a demo
of what sort of apps you can
build with the Realtime API.
We're then going to go into a
little bit more depth on the
technical details behind
Google's realtime
collaborative technology, which
is used in a lot of our
products, as well as
the Realtime API.
We're going to talk through a
few points about how you can
design a good data model and
avoid some of the potential
pitfalls that come from
collaboration.
And then finally, we're going
to give you a little sneak
preview of the things we're
working on to improve the
Realtime API for your
great apps.
So Cheryl, want to talk
a little bit about
the Realtime API?
CHERYL SIMON: Sure.
So at this point you guys are
probably wondering, what is
the Realtime API?
So I assume many of you have
used Google Docs before, or
least seen it.
So what the Realtime API does is
it allows you to take your
application and add to it
the power of instant
collaboration, just like what
you get in Google Docs.
It's all done client-side via a
JavaScript API, so you don't
even have to run your
own server.
But you get really powerful
collaboration with
click-by-click or
character-by-character view of
what your collaborators
are doing.
We handle conflict resolution.
So if multiple people are making
changes to the document
at the same time or to whatever
your application is.
And you can get collaborator
presence.
So you can see who else is
working on the document or
playing the game at
the same time.
And this is all backed by Google
Drive, which means that
you get the power of Google's
Cloud Storage Services, and
high availability, and all the
sort of ecosystem that comes
with Google Drive.
So now we're going to show
a quick demo, just so
you can just see.
So the Google Docs you're
familiar with are probably the
Docs, Sheets, and Slides that
are more productivity focused.
So we just thought we'd show a
quick demo of the other sort
of things you can do with
the Realtime API.
So this is a little game called
Realtime Cube that was
written by one of our Drive
developers, Mike Propcopio.
And you can see here that as
Brian makes a change to the
cube, that change is instantly
seen by all of the other
players in the game.
In the upper right, you can see
the other people that are
playing right now.
And because this is backed by
Google Drive, everything is
stored instantly.
So if you were to close and
reopen the game, you could
easily restore state.
So let's just think for a
second, what would it take to
build this kind of
collaboration system from scratch?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Oh,
I can do that.
CHERYL SIMON: Oh, yeah?
BRIAN CAIRNS: OK.
CHERYL SIMON: You think so?
All right, let's
think about it.
So first, you need some sort
of consistent storage,
someplace that all these bits
that represent the document
are going to be.
BRIAN CAIRNS: That's
simple, we'll just
throw it in a database.
CHERYL SIMON: OK.
Well, what about
authentication?
How are you going to know
who your users are?
BRIAN CAIRNS: I'm sure we can
do something with like a
cookie or maybe a session
ID, something like that.
CHERYL SIMON: All right.
What about your client
server protocol?
What sort of networking are
you going to have set up?
BRIAN CAIRNS: We'll use JSON and
come up with some sort of
serialization format.
CHERYL SIMON: OK.
How are you going to
handle conflicts?
What happens when multiple
people are making changes
together at the same time?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Well, we'll just
tell our users not to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
CHERYL SIMON: OK.
How about push notifications?
You at least have to be able
to tell the client when
there's new changes available.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Well, if we just
continuously make get requests
to the server, that pretty
much solves itself.
CHERYL SIMON: All right.
Well, what about document
management?
Or here's a good one,
server failover.
What do you do if your
server crashes?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So there's only
going to be one server.
So if it crashes, then
we'll reboot it.
CHERYL SIMON: OK.
Are you going to handle
undo/redo?
BRIAN CAIRNS: To
be determined.
CHERYL SIMON: OK.
Well, what about
authorization?
This is really important, you
don't want users to be able to
see each other documents or get
access to things that they
shouldn't have.
BRIAN CAIRNS: I can't
really come up with
anything for that.
CHERYL SIMON: Yeah.
All right.
Well, what about server
affinity, or data replication,
or user presence?
Or, how about sharing?
Or document metadata,
profiles?
BRIAN CAIRNS: I think this might
be a little bit harder
than I was thinking.
What if there were some kind
of an API that did
all of this for us?
CHERYL SIMON: Well,
luckily there is.
So with the Realtime API, you
can let us handle all of the
complication of network
communication, storage,
sharing, high availability,
all of that
is handled for you.
All you have to do is to create
a realtime data model
that makes sense for
your application.
So you can focus all your
energies on just creating
really awesome applications
that'll make
users really happy.
So what's the data
model look like?
Thinking back to that demo we
showed just a few minutes
earlier, this is a
representation of what this
data model could look like.
So at the root of the data
model is always a
collaborative map, which just
is where you put all of the
data objects that you need
for your application.
In this case, there's just a
single collaborator of list
that consists of the moves
that the players
have made in the game.
And each move is just
represented as a JSON object.
So these collaborative types,
this map and list, are special
in that whenever you add
something or make a change to
this map or to this list, the
changes are automatically sent
to the server and sent to all
the different collaborators.
So here, I'm going to show you
in one slide all the code that
you need in order to integrate
the Realtime API with this
data model I just
talked about.
So the first thing that you do
is you just load a file.
And when you load it, you have
to give it three things.
You have to give it the file
that you want to be loaded.
And then you give it two
function pointers, one that
represents the file--
what you want to happen when
the file is loaded, and one
that represents what you want
to happen the first time the
data model is initialized.
So let's look at that
second one first.
So this initialize model is
called exactly once for each
time that the data model
comes into existence.
So not every time the document
is loaded, just the first time
the document is created.
And here, you want to initialize
all the state that
you want to guarantee that every
document in your system
is going to have.
So here we tell the model to
create a list and that creates
a collaborative list.
And then we add it to the root
by just saying, set this thing
on the root with a
name of moves.
Then, on the onfileLoaded, this
is what happens every
time a collaborator opens
the document.
So what you want to do here is
to set up some listeners so
that you can be informed
of when changes
happen to this list.
So in this case, we're adding
an event listener onto that
moves object that we
created above.
And we're going to get notified
whenever a value is
added to the list.
And we just want to update the
display when that happens.
And then finally, you just need
a little bit of code to
respond to user actions.
So whenever a user makes a
move here, we'll tie this
addMove handler into it.
So we create a new move, which
is just a JSON object, and we
add it to this moves
collaborative list that we
created before.
And that's it.
With just these three simple
steps, all of those moves are
going to be automatically
sent around.
And you can update the display
and handle all of the sort of
complexity of networking
storage, all of that is
handled with just these three
simple functions.
And now Brian, here, is going to
tell us a little bit about
some apps that have already
put this to use.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Thanks, Cheryl.
So we have a lot of great
partners that made really
awesome apps for the
Realtime API.
We already demonstrated Realtime
Cube, which was
developed by a member of the
Drive team here at Google.
We also have some other
apps that were
developed by Google engineers.
Multi Sudoku was actually
developed by Cheryl.
It's just a Sudoku game and
it's really fun to play.
And then, we have another
developer, John Day-Richter,
who developed a make your own
adventure text-based game
called CollabQuest, which is
really cool if you're into
MUDs or something like that.
But maybe you're interested in
something that's a little bit
more productive than that.
If you like editing code--
and who doesn't--
we have a great cloud-based IDE
developed by one of our
partners called Neutron Drive.
Many of you have maybe
seen this or used it.
With the Real time API, now
you can collaborate on the
code you have stored in Google
Drive, just like you could
collaborate on a document
in Google Drive.
And this is really great for
para-programming or code
reviews, or whatever you want to
do to collaborate on code.
If you want to plan some sort of
project or a schedule, one
of our partners created
an app called Gantter.
And Gantter is a Gantt-plotting
program for
project management
and schedules
and things like that.
And now, of course, that's
a collaborative activity.
And you can now see people's
changes in realtime
as they make them.
Or, if you're into doing some
sort of diagramming, draw.io
has really great diagramming
tools.
You can make flow charts, or
network diagrams, or any kind
of diagram that you would
want to make.
And again, because of the
Realtime API, now you can do
this in realtime,
collaborating with other users.
So lots of really great
capabilities that the Realtime
API can bring to your apps.
And it's not just limited to
productivity apps, it could
work in games or whatever else
you can dream of that you want
to have realtime
collaboration.
Let's go through a few of
the secrets of realtime
collaboration.
How does this technology
actually work?
So what's the goal with realtime
collaboration?
Well, the goal is something
like this.
This experience where everyone
can edit at the same time, and
everyone can see everyone
changes in realtime.
But getting there is
not actually as
easy is it maybe seems.
Because we really want two
properties out of this system.
We want to be able to apply the
changes to the data model
immediately without waiting
for network latency.
Maybe you're on crappy hotel
internet connection or maybe
you're on the conference network
here at Google I/O and
it takes 500, 600, 700
milliseconds for things to go
to the server and back.
You can't wait that long to
update the local display.
But then, that means that
every user is seeing a
slightly different sequence
of events in a document.
And we need to come up with a
consistent answer at the end
where everyone gets the same
result, regardless of the
order or timing in which these
changes were applied.
And the way we do that is we
break every change you do to
the data model, we break
down into these
things called mutations.
And a mutation's just a simple
operation on the data model.
So let's go through
an example here.
Here we have just a string.
And we can assume this is
a collaborative string.
And the user starts with this
string, Hello World, and they
start typing in.
Well, we generate an
insert mutation.
Let's say that the user inserted
the word Realtime
between Hello and World.
Well, we generate this insert
mutation that says insert at
position six this
text Realtime.
When that gets applied, we end
up with Hello Realtime World,
as you would expect.
Then the user might decide,
OK, I want to
actually delete something.
Maybe I want to delete the
word "World." So again,
starting with Hello Realtime
World, the user goes in,
selects World, and backspaces
or whatever.
And we generate a delete
mutation that says to delete
starting at index 14, which is
where the word "World" begins,
these six characters.
And of course, once that's
applied, we erase that word
"World" and you end up
with Hello Realtime.
What this means for storage is
actually really interesting.
So one way you could store this
document is you could try
to store a snapshot of the
document, or some sort of
serialized form of the state.
What we do is actually
a little bit
simpler and more powerful.
We store the entire history of
mutations that are applied to
the document.
So as you edit, every edit gets
just stored in a log.
And this is append only.
And that means that we have the
complete history of every
state the document
has ever been in
throughout editing time.
The one challenge this creates
is that this log's going to
get really, really long.
And we don't want to send the
entire mutation history every
time you load the document.
So what we do is we have a thing
that takes a snapshot of
the mutation log.
It basically rebuilds the data
model from this log, and then
creates a new set of mutations
that is the minimal set of
mutations needed to recreate
the data model.
So in this case, we have
an inset, another
insert, and a delete.
And all of that gets condensed
down into a single insert that
recreates the final result.
And that's what we send
when we load.
As I said before, local
mutations get applied easy--
or immediately.
So in this case, we have two
different users, Alice and
Bob, who are both collaborating
on this single string.
If Alice inserts the word
"rainy" and Bob inserts the
word "brightly" at the same
time, we apply both of those
changes immediately locally.
So you can see that Alice gets
the rainy day dawned
immediately and Bob gets
the day dawned brightly
immediately.
And this is great, but it's
not collaborative.
So what you might think is, why
don't we just broadcast
these mutations around
and then apply
them when we get them?
And that sounds good, but the
problem is that the mutations
end up getting out of date.
And let's go through an example
for how this happens.
Let's look just at
Alice's state.
Alice starts with
The day dawned.
She applies the insert of
rainy, which she sent.
And she also applies Bob's
insert of the word "brightly."
The problem is, you don't
get the right result.
Bob's insert is too far to
the left in the string.
The index doesn't make any sense
because there was an
insert that occurred
before it.
And you end up inserting in
the middle of a word and
nothing works.
And that's the key takeaway
here, is that applying
mutations as is just
doesn't work.
What we really want to do is
take these same mutations, but
instead of applying Bob's
mutation directly, we somehow
fix Bob's mutation to shift it
over to where it should have
been, and apply that.
And when we do this, we get
the correct result.
Again, the key premise here is
Alice needs to apply something
that's been modified,
not the exact same
mutation that Bob applied.
And the way we do this is
through a process we call
transformation.
So let's go through
an example of how
transformation actually works.
Again, we have Alice and Bob.
They both send out
their changes.
Alice has the insert of the
word "rainy," Bob has the
insert of the word "brightly."
And they both apply those
immediately locally.
They both then, send those
to the server.
Let's say that Alice's
gets to Google first.
OK, the server looks at this,
sees that there's nothing that
Bob has yet sent
to the server.
So there's nothing
we need to do.
It just sends it over to Bob.
And Bob gets the
correct result.
We're good.
Bob now, his mutation that
inserts the word "brightly"
gets to Google.
Well, Google, our servers notice
that Alice's mutation
came before Bob's mutation.
And so Bob's mutation needs
to be fixed to be
in the correct location.
And it looks at the indexes
specifically here.
It notices that the insert that
Alice issued happened
earlier in the document than
the insert that Bob issued.
And so it shifts over Bob's
insert by the length of what
Alice inserted.
And this new transformed
mutation, which is now an
insert at position 20, is what
Alice actually gets.
Alice applies it, and everyone's
happy again.
Yay, we win.
But it turns out that's
not really enough.
Transforming on just the server
doesn't actually solve
the problem.
And the reason is that the
server doesn't know about
every change, possibly
until it's too late.
So let's go through
another example of
where this might happen.
Again, we have Alice and Bob.
Both issue the same mutations
they did last
time at the same time.
But this time, Bob's mutation
gets to the server first.
Well, the server doesn't
transform Bob's mutation
because there's nothing
previous to
transform it against.
So the server just sends
it onto Alice.
And of course, panic ensues and
Alice is going to get the
wrong result.
Alice now sends her mutation.
And let's say it gets to the
server after Bob's mutation
got to the server.
Well, the server's going to
transform it against Bob's
mutation because it knows about
Bob's mutation now.
But Bob mutation comes
later in the document
than Alice's mutation.
So in reality, the
transformation for this
doesn't do anything.
The mutation just gets sent
as-is over to Bob.
And of course, the server get
the correct result and Bob
gets the correct result,
but Alice didn't.
So how do we solve this?
Well, the solution is to put the
exact same transformation
logic we use on the server
on the client.
So we have this thing called
the transformation manager
that runs in every
single client.
In JavaScript, it runs on
the server in Java.
And we have this mutation queue
that we keep, which is
basically the list of all
mutations that a user has
issued but haven't yet been
acknowledged by the server.
In this case, Alice's insert
of the word "rainy" goes on
this queue as soon
as it's sent.
Let's say the server sent out
Bob's mutation unmodified.
Well, this transformation
manager on the client notices
that Bob's mutation needs to be
transformed because it was
not made with respect
to Alice's mutation.
So we send all the mutations
from the pending queue and the
mutations from the server
through this transformer
function, which is the same as
it is on the server, and we
get the fixed result.
And everything's fine now.
And then, the server just has
to acknowledge mutations.
The server, when it receives a
mutation, it just sends back
an acknowledgement that looks
very much like the mutation,
but it doesn't have to
have the actual data.
And the client just removes
the mutation
from the pending queue.
And that's how we manage
conflicts in the system.
That's how we keep everyone on
the same state despite the
fact that these mutations
happened in different orders.
So let's look at a use case,
Cheryl, where you have to undo
a user's change.
CHERYL SIMON: All right.
Thanks, Brian.
So a lot of times in the
productivity-focused apps, the
user wants to be able to just
hit a button and have his last
change get undone.
So it turns out that this is a
little bit complicated in a
collaborative environment
because it's possible that
since he made his last change,
other users have actually made
other changes to the document.
Well, it turns out that the same
transformation logic that
Brian just talked about can
actually help us solve this
problem, basically for free.
So let's just think
about what might
happen here for a minute.
So we start with this document,
The day dawned.
And the local user tries to
insert "brightly" into it.
So what we do is whenever the
local user makes a change, we
add a mutation to
the undo stack.
And what this mutation is, is
the inverse of the original
mutation, such that if you
applied this inverse mutation,
it would undo the original
mutation.
So in this case, the opposite of
inserting "brightly" is to
delete nine characters.
So now this undo stack consists
of a set of mutations
that'll sort of like reverse
the changes that the local
user has made.
And then later on in the
document, somebody else went
ahead and made some
more changes.
So if we just keep the undo
stack like that, and then we
try to go undo that user's
last change-- we pop this
inverse mutation off the stack
and go and apply it-- we run
into the same problem where this
inverse mutation doesn't
make sense anymore.
It goes and delete the wrong
section of the document.
So we can solve this.
So what we do, instead, is we
still store this inverse
mutation on the undo stack.
But in addition, we actually go
ahead and store all of the
collaborator mutations
as they come in.
So now this undo stack consists
of a combination of
inverse local mutations and
collaborator mutations.
Then, when the user asks us to
undo, what we do is we walk
down the stack and pop off all
the collaborator mutations,
until we find one that belonged
to the local user.
When that happens, we pull the
local user's mutation off and
we transform it against all of
the collaborator mutations
that have happened since.
So in this case, the delete gets
transformed against this
insert mutation from which we
know we need to shift the
delete over by four
characters.
So we get out this transformed
mutation, which when we apply
it the model, undoes exactly
what the user did before.
So we've talked a little bit
now about how all the stuff
sort of works behind
the scenes.
It turns out you really don't
have to know all that in order
to be able to use the API.
But it can come in handy a
little bit as you're designing
your data models to just
have a little bit of an
understanding of how these
conflicts are handled, so you
can understand the implications
of the choices
you're making in your
data model.
So now we're just going to go
through a few examples of data
models in this event planning
system so you can see some of
the challenges that come up
when you're working in a
collaborative system.
So in this event planning
system, you have a bunch of
tasks, each represented by
one of these blue cards.
And each task has some
properties associated with it,
like what the task is that has
to happen and how much time
it's going to take.
And then it's organized into
columns, where each column is
the work assigned to
a particular user.
So here's an example
of what this data
model might look like.
You could have a collaborative
map of users, each of which
contains a collaborative list
for each user, which in turn
contains the specific tasks
that are assigned to them.
And so one situation that might
come up is here we have
two properties, time and unit,
that are sort of intrinsically
tied together.
It doesn't really make sense
to update one of these
properties without also updating
the other one.
Or at least, they should
go together.
So how would you handle updating
these two properties
atomically?
Well, so this task is
represented by something
called a custom object, which is
basically just a fancy way
of being able to assign
names to specific
collaborative fields.
So that means that when you
change the values on these
fields, what you end up with are
two set mutations, one for
the unit and one for the time.
And this is all great as long as
only one person is making a
change at the same time because
you set the two
properties and you're happy.
But the problem comes in when
somebody else comes in and
makes a change at
the same time.
And the problem is that you
can't control the order in
which these changes happen.
It's left up to sort of the
vagaries of the network
communication.
So it's possible that half of
Salina's change is actually
going to come before Amir's
change, and the other half
comes after.
And so the result of this is
going to be that you have a
task that has the time from what
Salina tried to set it
to, but the units from what
Amir tried to set it to.
And this is obviously wrong.
You just don't want this
two changes to be
intermixing like this.
So what do you do?
We solved this with a concept
called compound operations.
So what a compound operation is,
is a way to tell us that
these mutations belong to a
set and should be applied
together at the same time.
So all you do to create a
compound operation is tell the
model you're beginning one.
And then you go and make a bunch
of changes to your data
model, like setting the units or
the time, and then you end
the compound operation.
And what happens now is the
mutations that resulted in all
the changes you made inside that
block get sent over the
network together as a set.
And you can guarantee that
they'll always be processed in
order with nothing else being
processed in between.
So now we know that Amir's
change is always going to be
processed fully before
we process anything
from Salina's change.
And so now we can guarantee that
the end task is going to
be in a consistent state.
Now, Brian's going to work
through a different example.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Thanks, Cheryl.
So here's another use
case that you
might see in this system.
Let's say you have
some priority
assigned to these tasks.
In this case, we have high,
medium, and low, but you might
have a real numbered priority
or something like that.
And you wanted to keep them
sorted in some sort of
priority order where high tasks
appear first in the UI,
and then medium, and then low.
Well, you might think the best
way to do this is to just sort
the data model.
But the problem is that any sort
you do in this system is
going to be represented to the
server and to every other
collaborator as a series
of inserts and deletes.
And there's nothing stopping
anyone from interleaving other
inserts or deletes in between
these changes.
Or, for that matter, two
people trying to
sort at the same time.
And the system has no knowledge,
the Realtime API
has no knowledge that you wanted
this to be sorted.
And as a result, it has no way
to know that these changes are
somehow interrelated in
very complex ways.
And the result you end up with
is that the sorted list is not
necessarily going
to stay sorted.
In this case, we have an insert
of a high priority task
first, and then an insert of
a medium priority task.
And of course, because the way
indexes work, the medium
priority task will end up first
in the list, which is
not what you want.
So the solution to this
kind of problem--
and this is actually a generic
solution that works with all
kinds of different problems
you end up with in the
Realtime API.
And it's very powerful, is to
keep your data model unsorted,
and then do a sort.
But only keep a sorted view
of the data model.
So this sorted view is something
that's just local to
your client and in memory.
And you might think that this
is very inefficient.
I mean, after all, sorting is
not necessarily the cheapest
operation and you might
be doing it a lot.
But the reality is you can be a
little bit lazier than that.
As it turns out, you can
sort just when the
user loads the document.
And then, you add listeners
to the unsorted view.
And as users insert or delete
items from the unsorted view
or move them around, all you
have to do is a simple binary
search on your view to figure
out what's the location of
those items.
And this sort of keep a modified
view, and then update
it based on listeners is a very
powerful technique that
can solve a wide variety
of problems.
So let's look at another task.
CHERYL SIMON: All right.
So another situation that you
want to be able to do in this
application is to assign tasks
to different users.
So you can do this just by
dragging something from one
column into another.
So this is a little bit
problematic, again, in a
collaborative environment
because this move is not an
atomic operation.
The move is actually going
to be represented by two
different mutations, a
delete and an insert.
And so again, if two people make
changes at the same time,
you end up with problems.
In this case, you end up with
having the task in two
different users' queues, which
is obviously not what you were
looking for.
So what do we do about this?
Well, one thing you might think
is a solution, because
it was a solution to a kind of
similar problem before, is
compound operations.
But it turns out that
this doesn't solve
this particular problem.
And the reason is that all a
compound operation does is
affect the order in which the
mutations are applied, but it
doesn't affect how the mutations
are transformed.
So in this case, we get these
two compound operations and we
still individually transform
every mutation within them
against every other mutation,
and then apply them
individually.
So the first transformation
is a [INAUDIBLE]
because we'll just assume
we don't have
any historical state.
But then the second one, we're
going to start with this
delete here and transform it
against the delete and the
insert that came before.
Here, the delete actually just
goes away, because the delete
already happened.
So it gets transformed in all.
But the insert is actually the
one that we want to go away,
and it doesn't.
Because if you transform the
insert against the delete and
the insert and the
delete that came
before it, nothing happens.
They're all affecting different
lists, so it doesn't
really affect the ability for
us to do this insert.
So it happens anyways.
So you still end up with a case
where you have the thing
inserted into two
different lists.
So what you want to do instead,
is to adjust your
data model to make it so that
this assignment is actually an
atomic operation.
So before, we had a list for
every individual user, which
represented the tasks that
belonged to the user.
What we could do instead is
just have a single list of
tasks and make the
assignee just a
field on the task object.
And because it's a field in a
custom object, it just becomes
a set operation.
And if you transform two set
operations against each other,
one of them is always
going to win.
So you guarantee that you'll
always have exactly one
assignee for the card, which is
what you were looking for.
So up till now, we've been
talking about things that you
can do in the API today.
So now Brian's going to give
us a little bit of a sneak
peak about what's
coming up soon.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Thanks, Cheryl.
So one thing that we've gotten
a lot of feedback on, and we
know that you value a lot, is
the ability to get your data
out of the Realtime API.
And there's a lot of reasons
you might want to do this.
You might want to backup your
data, or you might want to do
processing of the data in the
Realtime API on your server,
and we want to make
that possible.
So we're excited to announce
that we're going to be adding
the capability to the Drive API
to take a realtime data
model and export a JSON
representation
of that data model.
Now, because this is part of the
Drive API, you can use any
of the great client libraries we
have for the Drive API for
a variety of languages.
Or, if you want, you can just
use a very simple HTTP RESTful
call to download this
data model.
And again, we use OAuth
2.0 for this.
It's very simple
to get set up.
And you get this--
What the user does to the
document or whatever app
you're building, we always
generate a consistent format.
And it's designed to be easy
to understand from a human
perspective and easy for you
to work with in code.
Well, of course, the natural
follow-up to I can export the
data is, what do I do with
it once I get it out?
And so we're also going to be
adding the capability, again
to the Drive API, to take this
exported representation and
convert it back into a
realtime data model.
So let's say you have a JSON
that has been exported, and
maybe you've done some
modifications to it.
What you can do is you can
upload it to the Drive API.
Again, this is very simple using
our client libraries or
using a simple HTTP post call.
We then take that uploaded
representation and
reconstitute a realtime
data model.
This is our sort of
temporary model.
And we take this temporary
model, along with the current
data model as it exists on the
server, and we run them
through a diffing algorithm.
And the diffing algorithm
actually computes the
mutations that take the current
state that's on the
server and transform it into the
state that you uploaded.
In this case, there's an
insert and a delete.
And again, these are just
mutations, just like any other
mutations in the system.
And then what we do is we apply
these mutations back to
the data model on the server.
And the net result of this is
that if there were changes
going on, they actually end up
getting merged together.
And if you have collaborators
working on the document, they
see the final result
immediately.
They don't have to reload or
do anything like that.
They see the changes in realtime
just like they came
from any other collaborator.
And so we think this is a really
great capability that
you're all going to love
and use in cool ways.
But we also understand that
you might want to have the
full richness of the Realtime
API and programming model in
different contexts.
And of course, one of the
obvious contexts is you want
to develop a mobile app.
So we're also excited to
announce that we're working on
an Android Java API for
the Realtime API.
So this will give you the same
sort of great, easy to use
objects, collaborative
objects, and other
capabilities as our JavaScript
API, but in a Java
environment.
And I should say, we want this
to work really well on
Android, so we're doing a lot of
work on things like keeping
CPU usage low and making
sure that we're not
using a lot of bandwidth.
But this is a generic
Java API.
So if you want to use it in a
desktop Java application, or
you want to use it in a
server-side Java application,
that's great, too.
And it'll work wonderfully.
And of course, because we have
this sort of data model that
we've built from the ground
up, we can provide
cross-platform compatibility.
So the Java API and the
JavaScript API work on the
same data models.
And we automatically translate
between types for you.
So if you have a collaborative
string, for example, in
JavaScript, you get the
JavaScript object, the
gabi.drive.realtime.collab
string.
Which will have the properties
and other things that you
expect from a JavaScript
implementation.
If you take that same data model
and load it with the
Java API, what you'll get is
another collaborative string
but written in Java.
And the Java version will
support the same interfaces
that you expect from Java,
things like appendable.
So this makes it a great way to
build cross-platform apps
that share the same data.
CHERYL SIMON: So that's all
we have for you today.
I hope you guys learned a little
bit about the Realtime
API, and how it can make it
really easy for you to add
collaboration to your
own applications.
And I hope you have a little bit
better of an understanding
of how it works behind the
scenes, so this can help you
design really good data models
that will make your
applications just work
really well.
But now it's your turn.
So we think we have a really
great technology here that can
enable some really amazing
applications.
But you guys are the ones with
the great application ideas.
So we just hope that you
can go out there
and put this to use.
And we're really excited to
see what you have going.
So now we have time for
a few questions here.
And if you don't want to stick
around, we'll be upstairs in
the Chrome Apps area later on
this afternoon, so you can
come find us.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I was just
curious about your
implementation for that.
Do you guys use WebSockets
or long polling?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
So we use long get requests.
So we use cores to do
cross-origin communication.
And sort of the design of the
system is we want to be
transport agnostic.
So we used long gets because we
want to have compatibility
with older browsers, like we
support Internet Explorer 9.
But we haven't seen a huge
advantage of going to
WebSockets at this point.
If that's something that is
something we want, that'll be
something that'll be transparent
to your app.
And again, on the Java API, and
all of the other APIs we
do, are not necessarily
going to use the
same transport mechanism.
AUDIENCE: And then, my other
question was, so one of the
things that you get with Google
Apps is the ability to
have revision history.
Is that something that
we have with this?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So we have not
yet exposed the revision
history for documents.
It's something we're
already keeping.
And we don't have anything to
announce right now, but that
would definitely be a capability
that would be
really cool to have.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, John Blossom.
It sounds like you've avoided
certain things that were in
Wave protocol, such as XMPP
underpinnings and going to
character-by-character updates
and things of that sort.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Well, I should
say, we can do
character-by-character
updates.
AUDIENCE: You can.
But if I understand from the
examples, that's not what
you're doing in terms of
managing the stack of updates.
BRIAN CAIRNS: So an update could
be a single character
insert or a single
character delete.
We have, basically, a throttling
algorithm in place,
so that we batch up updates so
that we're not using tons and
tons of bandwidth for
single characters.
AUDIENCE: So, in effect,
what you have is a
micro-timer if you will.
If somebody's a fast typer,
then that's one update?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Right.
And in fact, the algorithm's
actually somewhat adaptive.
So it tries to prioritize
low latency if
updates are coming slowly.
And then, it tries to
prioritize bandwidth
efficiency if updates are
coming more quickly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
Thank you.
On the JSON exporting of the
data, you're exporting the
data model.
And as you said, it would be
nice if you could export the
history stack.
Is there any provision of being
able to export access
capabilities for a
federated model?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So we don't have
anything to announce
right now on that.
I would love to chat about that
if you want to come to
office hours, though.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thanks.
CHERYL SIMON: Gentleman
in the back.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a maximum
number of subscribers
or collaborators?
BRIAN CAIRNS: I think the
maximum number is 50.
Beyond that, the more
collaborators you get, they
end up in a read-only mode.
So it's 50 actively editing
collaborators at a time.
AUDIENCE: So you can have
anonymous collaborators that
don't collaborate?
They're kind of read-only?
Could use it kind of like as
a PubSub kind of thing?
BRIAN CAIRNS: We're probably not
the best thing to use as a
PubSub kind of thing.
But, I mean, yeah, that's
certainly a use case that you
might consider if you like other
properties of the API.
AUDIENCE: How would you
represent something like a
Google Docs, which has on one
hand, like a large body of
text, and on the other hand,
like the possibility to modify
individual characters
and attributes?
So what kind of data model
would you use for that?
CHERYL SIMON: So you're asking
what kind of data model you
would use to represent, like
a Google document?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Format.
AUDIENCE: Yes, formatting.
CHERYL SIMON: Oh,
the formatting.
Well, obviously the string
is pretty easy.
We have a collaborative string,
which we didn't really
talk about here, but which
automatically handles all the
updates and edits
to the string.
And we also have this thing
called index references, which
is a way for you to sort of put
a pointer at a location in
the string and it will
automatically shift rounds
with the updates.
And so we actually, historically
had a version of
this working with these index
references, where basically
you can mark the beginning
and end of formatting
areas in order to--
and then you can apply that
at the rendering phase.
BRIAN CAIRNS: And let's
try to take a
question, if we can, from--
CHERYL SIMON: While he's
setting that up,
you want to go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
How do you handle authorization
in the data
model in terms of segmentation
of what certain users or
certain roles can have access
to edit or not access?
CHERYL SIMON: So the Realtime
Docs are just Google Documents
in Google Drive.
So we use their sharing and
authorization services.
So you can have viewers and
editors, and you can actually
integrate with the common
sharing dialog in order to
have that all be configured.
AUDIENCE: So that's
at the document
level, the entire document?
BRIAN CAIRNS: The unit of
access controls at the
document level and each one
will have a document ID.
And you can manipulate these
with Drive API if you want to
do permissions or whatever.
You can have multiple documents
open at the same time.
So if you want to have--
in a single application, you
want to have different parts
that have different access
rules, that's definitely
something you can do.
And in fact, something
when Neutron Drive
does exactly that.
AUDIENCE: Is that multiplexed
over the same connection then?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So right now
we do not have connection
multiplexing.
There's a separate browser
channel for each one of those.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to use
the Realtime API for an
offline sync?
So two users make changes
independently offline and then
want to sync them?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So we don't
currently have offline
capability, except I should
note the import/export
capability is actually a pretty
decent way to do offline.
I think we're a little bit out
of time, but I would be happy
to talk about different ways you
could implement offline if
you'd like to come
to office hours.
And I should say, office hours
is immediately, right now,
after this talk upstairs in the
Chrome section over by the
question booth.
Thank you all.
CHERYL SIMON: Thanks.